[Music]  I am wearing an Alexander McQueen dress  Wow  it's more than my mortgage I'm aware  distress multiple-time  Tiffany Haddish made good on her promise  the comedian wore her beloved McQueen  dress for a third time to the 2018  Oscars we are so happy to be here but I  feel I have to take my shoes off girl me  too I've been wearing these shoes since  11 o'clock this morning how long you  been wearing your shoes since the  Critics Choice Awards oh yeah that's  Tiffany wearing her gorgeous gown with  ugh slippers on stage always living her  best life Oh Oh Tiffany and Maya Rudolph  brought the laughs as they presented two  awards TIFF even got a bit starstruck by  a certain someone in the front row hi  Meryl I want you to be my mama one day  [Applause]  this one day let's get this money girl